la justicia peruana ordenó el
impedimento de salida del país contra el
expresidente de martín vizcarra por 18
meses para la corte existe el peligro de
fuga y los delitos son graves y
comprenden elevadas penas la jueza maría
álvarez al admitir la orden dijo que el
caso es complejo y compromete a varios
implicados la fiscalía había solicitado
la medida para evitar una probable fuga
mientras se investiga al exmandatario
por delitos de probable peculado y
presuntos sobornos por la construcción
de un proyecto de irrigación y un
hospital cuando martín vizcarra se
desempeñaba como gobernador de moquegua
una región al sur del perú la ordenanza
emitida por el primer juzgado de
investigación preparatoria nacional
permanente señala que el impedimento
contra vizcarra rige a partir de la
fecha y culminará el 12 de mayo de 2022
al respecto el ex mandatario momentos
antes del fallo señaló que no tiene
ningún interés por salir del perú y se
quedará para luchar por la democracia